I am standing with the icon of uptown
style dapper down that's some that
you've got it
this handshakes a little crazy you don't
stop do you plenty of water out me what
are you doing there you've been
responsible for so many iconic looks can
you show me some of you oh yeah let me
show you what's this right here this is
no this is the fat boy yeah that's the
fat boys okay incredible Eric being
Rakim okay you've styled them well salt
and pepper and that's something I've got
long legs and I'm very feminine killin
leggings though I like leggings do you
like leggings I like the way they hug
the body it was actually serious what
happened there oh this isn't working for
me Oh can I be honest with you this has
never worked for me okay so I'm gonna
invite you into the domain of swag
Harlem 3 this is what you grow Harlem
swear this is Harlem swag this is
Holloway what would this be called right
here casual disdain no it's okay if you
pass them through I'm a guy just passing
through yeah we want to do is we want to
try and bump me up a notch I want the
look I want the dapper dan look that's
what I'm gonna give you and we're gonna
just swag you up and down you're gonna
swag me up and down swag you all the way
up and down okay sounds a little weird
gotta have some swag when you walk you
gotta walk a little I'm gonna show you
my walk and you tell me what you think
of it he walked
like that one no you gotta keep walking
without me no late I'm late this is me
late you've got
[Applause]
too much and it looks like I haven't had
my medicine you got to have the shoulder
there okay fire fire hydrant nice I'm
trying to get away before the cops show
up man swag me up that's right
hey Dad yeah I found something
oh great great great is this a pee-wee
Herman special we get ready look at this
this spoke to me I saw this and you know
it didn't spoke to it cursed at you this
is not sweat does anyone know what
neighborhood this is where would I go
away so you like to spin the spend my
works if you can just keep doing it so
they don't see what's going on yeah give
me a minute to try this on my own okay
[Applause]
you like plaid plaid plaid plaid plaid
no you look fabulous to me coming up to
New York to be a pimp listen you think I
look like a pimp
no it looks like somebody trying to be
Apep wait I don't even look like a pimp
I look like a guy who's trying to be up
him exactly unemployed I'm an unemployed
thank you please yeah yeah you ready
yeah I'm ready
now this outfit here listen it looked
like you was nominated for five BT
Awards and you know five outfits and you
warm all at the same time maybe the
jackets too much maybe when I take off
the jacket you see a see-through shirt
[Applause]
like that look at that
[Applause]
you like it you say this is not an
authentic Harlem look no okay absolutely
no I think you're wrong I would like to
go outside and get a second opinion or
two you might let's go what do you think
of my outfit I don't like it you think
you don't like it you did its do you
know what do you think I look attractive
in this last you I agree that you
probably have the better idea so why
don't you swag me up you do it swagged
up my dad back style let's go do it
[Applause]
we're dead
[Applause]
let's give it up for my tailor very very
Lauria
damn your genius
[Applause]
[Music]
you